do you  have a distinction in your in your head  between  political  action  versus  non-political action  uh as  and are they both  uh covered by philanthropy  in much of the world where i have  experience it takes both  to try to  support in what might be considered  traditional philanthropy  ignoring the power and the politics  can be very frustrating  just focusing on the politics  is also dangerous and to me it's it's  the balance and i see that in the united  states  on a national state regional level i see  it throughout the developing world i see  it  basically wherever wherever i go it's  very hard to find large complicated  issues  that don't touch on politics